the children produced strong antibody
responses and showed no serious side
effects
now the study included more than 2 200
kids
here in the united states the company
will now give this information to the
fda to expand the use
in the 12 to 15 year age group the
vaccine is currently authorized
in the u.s for individuals 16 years of
age or older
now last week pfizer and biotech began
their global study and dosed
the first healthy children ages 6 months
to 11 years today's state of health
officials told us
the following during the daily covet
update
as they are able to publish the data
goes through the fda
process the advisory committee
immunization practices and so
we'll lean on that on that those
recommendations and what that data shows
as we move through that particular age
population
well this is a big step forward as we
continue to transition students back
to the classroom now if approved
vaccinations could start before the
beginning of the next academic school
year
for middle and high school students now
moderna has also been testing its
vaccine in children
those results are expected over the next
few weeks christian cassette is 8 news
now